Here are the correct answers negative 1. Great work if found that one. We start
solving this equation by multiplying both sides by the LCD this leaves us with 2
times x minus 8 minus 6 times 2x minus 1 on the left hand side of the equation.
On the right hand side we'll still have 0 since 0 times any factor would still
be 0. Next we distribute and combine our like terms to get negative 10x. Minus
10 equals zero. We rewrite this sign up here, and then solve for x. We add 10 to
both sides, and then we divide both sides by negative 10. This gives us our
final value of negative 1. For the excluded values, we want to look at these 2
denominators to figure out what x cannot equal. We know x cannot equivalent half
or this denominator here equals 0. Likewise we know x cannot equal positive 8 or
this denominator would be 0 as well. Our final answer is not one of these
excluded values. So here is our only solution, negative 1. Notice that there is
another way to solve this equation. If we move this second fraction to the right
side of the equation we would have one fraction equal to another. We would just
add this to both sides of our equation. Next we would multiply by the LCD or
simply cross-multiply to get this next equation. After distributing and solving
for x, we would find x would be equal to negative 1. If you use this method,
that's great.